what's going on everybody welcome to
part 6 of the quanto peon tutorials in
the previous tutorial we covered how to
build our pipeline data and basically
that's going to be the pipeline that
we're going to use in our trading
strategy which I mean the pipeline is
basically the crux of at least a simple
strategy where you can hopefully
calculate everything you need to or at
least as much as possible within the
pipeline and then and then you can make
trades based on that so in our case
we've computed what all the things that
we need actually because we've got
Long's and shorts and every day we would
just ask okay what are the companies our
Long's whatever in our Schwartz make
sure our portfolio consists of that done
now what we can do those with this
pipeline we can return the data which
will just be the sentiment data and
analyze alpha lens to analyze the alpha
factor which is sentiment factor or at
least what we hope to be an alpha factor
so up to this point I really haven't
talked too much about alpha and beta at
the simplest level alpha is the is a
measure of your returns that are is
basically irrespective of the market
gains so you want alpha to be high
because basically we have to compare
trading strategies to what about just
buying and holding the like at the SP
500 index fund so buying and holding the
SP 500 index fund has no almost no risk
I just got market risk but but it's got
not much risk so anytime you decide to
do trading you're introducing risk also
buying and holding the the S&P 500 index
fund is also going to give you dividends
for example which trading you're not
going to get those so we make the
decision to trade it's really important
that we're doing it for the right
reasons so sometimes it might be to
actually hedge the market so maybe maybe
your objective isn't actually to beat
the market it's just a hedge it or
decrease volatility or something like
that there's a lot of reasons people
actually get into the market so anyway
alpha is something we want to be very
high we'd like it to be as high as
possible
and then beta is basically you know a
measure of your returns that are
basically attributed to the market so
you'd like beta to be neutral you don't
want it negative because you're you're
basically doing the opposite of the of
the market and you don't want it highly
positive because then it's like your
returns are just basically a multiple to
some degree of the market returns
already so we don't want that we want
neutral beta as close to zero as
possible
quanto peein likes to see anything
between negative point 3 and positive
point 3 alpha you just want it to be
positive as positive as possible so
anyway
alpha lens is going to analyze the alpha
miss of something before we get too far
I'll just bring up I'm not sure these
are the actual latest alpha lens docs
but you can also check out I just
actually pulled up something here but
whoops I didn't want to go that far back
I just want to go to alpha lens you can
also come to the github and kind of look
through alpha lens at least at the
moment isn't actually too complex so I'm
not really certain that a lot of
documentation is even required at this
stage but you can kind of poke through
and that's kind of what I was doing I
was looking at the tearsheet
which i'll talk about momentarily so so
yeah let's let's go ahead and jump into
working with alpha lens just so we can
see the output so first of all in your
when you run a backtest what's going to
happen is you're going to take your
pipeline data which contains a bunch of
tickers and then basically if you want
to make a trade all the back tester
really has to do is be like okay if
you'd like to make a buy what's the
price checks the price cool we'll save
that until you want to make a sell you
know you make a sound it's like what's
the price right now and sells whereas
with alpha lens the objective is to
compare your sentiment factor or your
factor does it have to be a sentiment
factor your factor over time over the
entire trading period compare your
factor to mark to the market returns of
all the assets you might be interested
in and it's just going to generate alpha
there so what you want to do is you want
to you want to abstract away as much as
possible the and pull away your strategy
you don't really want to check alpha for
your strategy so much as you do for
this signal because if the city either
the signal has alpha or it doesn't but
just because you run a backtest and you
make money that doesn't really mean that
the signal you were trading on actually
had any alpha you might have just got
lucky so it takes a few back tests to
find out also if you run a backtest you
didn't make money that also doesn't mean
your signal didn't have alpha it just
meant your strategy was bad so instead
what you can do is you can just test the
alpha so that's what we do with alpha
ones so first what we need to do is it
like I said in the back test it just
checks prices when you make the trade
but what we want to do is is check
prices throughout the entire period
basically of this signal which is
basically from you know the month the
year of 2015 so what we're gonna do
first is we need to know what assets we
need prices on because we don't want to
track the prices on all 8,000 companies
so our say assets equals result dot
index dot levels one dot unique so what
the hell does that mean
so result is our pandas dataframe index
is the index which happens to be it's a
dual index right the index you know this
this index is the date this index is the
ticker so we want the first if this
index and we want to know all the unique
tickers for that entire data frame and
then let's go ahead and just Len assets
just so we can see so we're dealing with
five hundred and twenty two companies
that we want to get pricing on so now
we're gonna say pricing equals get
pricing red flags bells should go off
you never imported get pricing well
guess what it's they're just some more
quanto peon magic for you assets
basically what prices on what are we
interested in we're interested in prices
for all of the assets and then we got
start date and end date so let's just
take this copy paste and then I'm gonna
say fields equals open price all right
so here what we have is basically the
exact same dates but I'm actually going
to knock the
down a month and I'm gonna knock this
one up a month and the reason we're
doing that is so we have a little bit of
data prior to our signal and a little
bit of data after because alpha lens is
gonna look a little bit prior and a
little bit after like after to continue
computing market returns and a little
bit prior because we can actually look
at what was pricing doing before the
like quote-unquote event of our signal
so we want a little bit of data on both
sides there all right let's run that
should have been running that while I
was talking it can take a few seconds
but it shouldn't be too bad so just as a
quick note take note of how long it
takes for this to run because we're
getting minute pricing data for all
these companies at least I think it's
minute maybe it maybe it might be daily
I don't know anyway it's a lot of
pricing data and it's going to happen
very fast so now I'm going to go ahead
and import alpha lines and then coming
down we're gonna do alpha lens dot tears
not that way
tears dot create factor tear sheet
notice pricing already finished crazy
okay what is the factor that we want to
like look into that we're hoping as an
alpha factor say factor equals results
and we just want the sentiment column of
results so we're gonna say results
sentiment and then we're gonna say okay
what do we compare this to so we're
comparing it to prices obviously and
prices will be pricing then we're gonna
say quantiles and we're gonna say
quantiles is equal to two
I'll explain quantile is here in a
minute because I'm gonna go on a rampage
here periods equals 1 5 and 10 ok so
periods is just what periods do want to
kind of like think about in our tear
sheets so this is one period forward 5
and 10 so that's like 1 day 5 days 10
days so maybe this data is I don't know
I'm trying to think you could get
probably index and grab like the second
0th index to find out if this is daily
or minute anyway that's okay
I'm still on that you guys are probably
moved up way
that by now so anyway so but this is
days so at least I think so cool so
coming here to quantiles always
quantiles basically what it's going to
do is take our sentiment data separate
it into two groups these groups before
separation are meant to come from a
signal that or I guess a factor that is
going to range from low to high
it must right now range from low to high
so if you have something such as
price-to-book ratio where it's not
that's not a factor that ranges from low
to high to low over priced a book we
start to wonder what is so wrong with
this company that it's worth less than
its tangible assets and a really high
price to book ratio is also not good
unless you're a technology company or
something like that you know then you
can start to justify higher but anyway
the higher it gets the worse it is but
also the lower it gets the worse it is
so if that's yours it doesn't mean you
can't use it what you probably need to
do is do some sort of calculation of the
deviation and then and have it ordered
that way also with quantiles the one of
the major problems with like for example
sentiment in theory wouldn't it be nice
because this signal is negative 3 to
positive 6 in theory there's 10 buckets
because you could have a zero as well
wouldn't it be nice if we could say we
want 10 quantiles in quantile you know
one would be the negative 3 and then
quantile 10 would be a positive 6 that
would be nice but what happens let's run
it did I do it right yeah ok it's
processing well hopefully we're gonna
get an error I don't want to eat my yeah
so look at this huge error but basically
it boils down to down here bin edges
must be unique so we can see as it tried
to evenly distribute by sample number
into these bins it failed because we had
too many negative threes way too many
negative ones too many ones just the
right number of two's though the right
number of fours and too many sixes okay
so it wants to vary it wants to evenly
distribute into these
or quantiles when really it would be
nice to be able to just say just evenly
distribute by the scale that we have or
something that would be nice
now in the documentation the reason I
was here is I was looking and like you
can see quantiles equals 5 here that's
probably really small that's huge
ok good so quantized equals 5 but we can
come down here to get this beautiful
docstring by the way I love it
quantile it can be int or it could be a
sequence of floats eg here
that's live on quanta or the github but
on actual quanto peon there using an
older version it just hasn't been
updated yet update it ok so it's just
probably not it's just not that
important compared to probably other
things anyways so we're gonna go with 2
because 2 works and that's ok because
again as long as you can do 2 which you
should always be able to do 2 on a range
the lowers should be bad the upper
should be good so we're gonna go with 2
but just know like if you're watching
this like a month from now from the
release date of this video or or more or
whatever just know that you can probably
get away with defining your buckets now
right you could define as however you
like but right now you can't so if
you're watching this right when I
release it you tough look ok running
hopefully no errors usually it spits out
the first table pretty quick there it is
okay so it's not everything that's gonna
generate it just a ton of graphs for us
but we'll start anyway so I'm just gonna
run over the the main things that I
think you want to pay attention to I'm
gonna skip over a lot of this you can
either learn more here let me see if
they have I'm not sure they've defined
much on out yeah whoo that's loud ok man
alright but you can learn more about
alpha lines both in the github and then
over here you can kind of learn a little
bit more if you'd like but I'll do my
best to explain what we're looking at so
anyways this is your annual alpha path
the greatest the beta though is
fantastic it's almost new
again you want it to be anywhere between
negative 0.3 positive 0.3 we're very
close to zero awesome down here the
information coefficient basically what
you're what you're hoping for here is to
have a value that is you know 0.1 is
fantastic point oh one is pretty good
anything less than that you know the
further you deviate from there the worse
it gets but basically what it's asking
is what's the rank correlation between
your factor values and the returns but
just look for 0.01 or point one ideally
then obviously we've got the standard
deviation which you know compared to our
actual values here that's a you know
pretty significant anyway going down
here we've got turnover which is
important but I think there's other
graphs that are more valuable than the
table so this is the main like the first
after you look at your alpha your beta I
would come down here this is really
useful because what you can see here is
this is you know the mean return by
Factor quantile over time so periods
like so after one day five days ten days
one day five day 10 days so quantile
this is quantile one quantile too so
quantile one sure enough after we get
the signal one day later the mean drop
five days later mean drop ten days later
even further okay and quantile to same
thing only vice versa so that's good
we're very happy there scrolling on down
uh-oh we're not locked we're kind of a
like our parade has been rained on
because this is a nice violin chart
that's kind of showing us that yeah the
mean is what we wanted but the the
deviation from that mean the volatility
that we have here and the spread is huge
that's going to be the main problem with
with this factor so and as we can see
you know the positive is much more
valuable to us than the shorts are
because we're making a lot of mistakes
here okay now the next kind of I think
six charts are just like this you've got
the long short and then the comparison
by quantile so here it's factor waited
long for
portfolio cumulative return over time so
this is assuming basically if you
shorted your quantile one longed
quantile to so all the companies that go
in there and remember this is relative
so like during this time we did very
badly but it's totally possible that
most companies during this time actually
had positive sentiment
so yeah it's falling because we're
investing into comfort or shorting
companies that actually have positive
sentiment but they just so happen to be
the worst positive sentiment so again
that's probably why you'd want to hard
cook be able to hard-code your bin edges
and quantiles back to our or graphs here
let's get back to where we were ok long
short over one period and then this one
just splits them up so you can kind of
see and in this case oh you know it's
just the inverse and that's mostly
probably happening because we literally
have two two groups so that kind of
makes sense that they would be
relatively flipped coming on down here
same graphs just over five periods same
graphs over ten periods so yeah cool
coming down here top minus bottom mean
return this just shows us holy-moly all
the noise that we have the mean is good
and what that kind of signals to me at
least is like right here like these
charts are like you literally are
longing in shorting and as we get to the
bottom two with the whole turnover we
have very low turnover so it's totally
possible that we're holding these
companies that have like let's say
negative sentiment that we're trying to
short we're we're shorting that company
until the sentiment changes we have no
stop-loss all right stop-loss probably
help us out here so anyway yet more
turnover basically you just have a ton
of noise or not turnover rather the mean
return but all this noise okay then here
you've got a vilage average cumulative
returns by quantile and take note the
order has been swapped on you so up to
this point quantile one has been green
quantile two is red but they flip them
on us so now quantile two is red so this
line here is like where you where the
signal happened
so what happened after the signal
happened for quantile to the good
quantile well it went up great on
quantile one the pad quantile what
happened after the signal it went down
but we can also see leading up to that
signal what happened basically the same
thing we just watched so basically what
we know to be the case at this point is
that in general sentiment seems to be
trailing what otherwise is is returns we
still had alpha it's still good and
predictive but it's trailing so that's
something you want to just think about
now coming on down here kind of the same
chart as above you got the nice event
horizon here but you've you've got this
the spread so the mean is down but you
also can see the spread of you know
basically how wrong are you and it's
important to notice too like here yeah
the mean and it spreads all the way up
you know past 80 basically and this one
only goes down to about you know minus
40 coming over here you've got this
spread basically all the way down to
about minus 40 and up here up to about
20 you've got just a massive spread
you're more likely to be wrong when
you're wrong on the shorts it looks like
and also you can just tell by the mean
line itself it's just not as negative as
the positive is positive so it could
also just be the case that you know is
the sentiment signal only buy into
positive sentiment don't let negative
sentiment dictate a buy or sell
coming on down here this is just
information coefficient over time
nothing really too much to see there and
then also you can see you know basically
over the years your monthly five period
I see so just very specifically you know
these are your months these are your
ears quantile turn over rank
autocorrelation and we are done okay so
I just quickly ran through the charts
basically I think you can get pretty
much the main bulk of information you
need from you know alpha beta come down
cool come down here and and these these
are like the first charts you should
look at and immediately when we see this
huge spread we already kind of know the
rest of what we're about to see in the
rest of this
at least for this signal but these are
still pretty pretty useful to see like
what happened what's happening over time
for this signal okay so at this point
given the workflow that we've talked
about you would almost certainly go back
and okay sentiment hat is is okay alpha
factor but you know and in a strategy
we'd probably want to stop loss but
we're gonna need some more alpha factors
we want to combine alpha factors so we
would okay we've got sentiment cool
write that down
let's find another alpha factor and find
a few alpha factors and then you combine
those alpha factors before you would do
a back test most likely now what I'm
gonna do now though is you know
basically the research of alpha factors
and combining those that's like the
challenge of quanto peon and in making a
good strategy I'm gonna leave that
challenge to you now going to since we
have some alpha here let's take it to a
back like an actual back test so we're
gonna back test in the next tutorial and
basically that back test is you know
pretty much this pipeline right here and
then we'll back test it and then we'll
come back here and feed the back test
through PI folio and see what more we
can learn so anyways that's it for this
in the kind of intro to alpha lines if
you have any questions comments concerns
whatever feel free to leave them below
otherwise I'll see you in the next
tutorial and we'll back test this bad
boy